we're gonna begin with this Iran said
overnight it broke up a CIA spy ring and
arrested 17 Iranians recruited to
collect information on the country's
nuclear and military sites now officials
claims some of those arrested have
already been sentenced to death
this comes as Britain convenes an
emergency meeting over Iran seizure of a
British flag oil tanker in the Strait of
Hormuz Iran accused the tankers crew of
various legal infractions and the
incidents come amid an escalating
showdown between Iran and the West as
the landmark 2015 nuclear deal continues
to unravel MTS ty Abbas in the United
Arab Emirates MTS what's iran saying
this morning good morning guys yeah that
dramatic news coming from Iran's
intelligence ministry saying that
they've arrested 17 suspects who they
say and I quote here that they've
confessed to acting as spies for the CIA
now Iran has made claims like this
before in the past and they're
impossible to verify at this stage but
these claims follow dramatic turn of
events here in the Gulf in which a
British flag tanker was seized by
Iranian commandos and is currently in
Iranian custody really ratcheting up
tensions here this video released by
Iran's Revolutionary Guard apparently
shows in real time the British flag
stena in peril oil tanker forced into
Iranian territorial waters radio
recordings also captured the moment a
British warship warned the Iranians not
to interfere with the vessel zero
degrees immediately over definitely
patrol bait this is British warship
Foxtrot 236 please confirm you are
intending to violate international law
attempting to the MV Center but minutes
later Iranian commandos took control of
the vessel apprehending the
international crew and replacing the
Union Jack with the flag of Iran this
morning Prime Minister Theresa May is
considering retaliation including
freezing Iranian assets the seizure of
the stena Impero comes just two weeks
after the UK's Royal Marines help seize
an Iranian tanker off the coast of
Gibraltar it's believed the vessel was
carrying oil to Syria in breach of EU
sanctions iran's Foreign Minister had
this to say about the seizure and
economic sanctions from the West this is
economic terrorism pure and simple we
need to repeat it again now the u.s. is
trying to pull together a sort of
maritime coalition to protect the ships
that travel through this region a lot of
ships traveling through this region but
they've been struggling to get help
particularly from the Europeans who we
understand are angry that President
Trump withdrew from that Obama era
nuclear deal a deal they say was crucial
to preventing things like this from
happening and is really behind the
spiraling tensions here in the Gulf
tensions hi there in the Golan yes taya
thank you very much we appreciate it